we do have a very special guest yeah on
the board of the st. Louis chess club
which helps make so much happen in the
city and of course in the international
chess world we have a Doug Eckert yes
we're with feet a master Doug Eckert who
is on the board of st. Louis chess club
also is a tax partner with brown smith
and wallace welcome to the show great
thank you I tell us first of all about
your involvement on the board how long
you've been on there and and why is it
that you have decided to take this
position well I'm on the board for the
last two years and i think that the
chess club's contributed quite a bit to
st. Louis and obviously to the chess
world and it's an exciting opportunity
to participate in that I first I also
want to congratulate you for your fine
article in the st. Louis Business
Journal where you draw a great
connections between chess and business
tell us more about that sure so every
week the st. Louis Business Journal has
what's called a character and they're
trying to talk about people's hobbies
and how they enter related with their
career and I mean chess has been sort of
a focus in my life it's helped me with
problem solving skills and being a taxi
PA I mean that's a very problem
orientated profession and they work very
well together so they wrote a nice
article it's kind of funny it's kind of
serious and it helps promote you know
both Brown Smith walls as well as chess
and the st. Louis Community you your
partner is over browse with what was
making fun of you for being famous now
absolutely you got to have some fun at
my expense that's part of the deal I
hear you're also involved in the 2006
golf tournament here in st. Louis tell
us about that so every year we have a
golf tournament in the first week in
October and the purpose of the golf term
is to raise funds for the Scholastic
program and right now in st. Louis we
service over 200 schools and over 2,000
students and just is very good at
helping students develop critical
thinking skills it's going to help Makka
demica Lee as well as with their
profession of the future and we think
it's an exciting program and this is our
way of raising money for those programs
to expand it and hopefully continue to
promote the game no Maurice you've
obviously been a part of that as well
and we appreciate your efforts in that
and maybe you can tell us a little bit
about
also I'm the one conducting this oh you
are oh I can't turn this around sorry
you're you are a feed a master you must
love having something like the same fill
cup here in st. Louis yeah I mean it's
great to see all these players I mean
it's hard for people understand how good
these are an attention that's in these
games I mean it's unbelievable the ideas
they come up with then it's fantastic
what's your fondest memory as a chess
player do it do anything special in your
life participating in the nineteen
eighty-four US Junior closed and it gave
me an opportunity to play with ten or
twelve of the very best junior players
in the country and you know it's hard to
believe that was in nineteen eighty four
thirty two years ago but I'm still
friends with all those guys in that
tournament and I think every year we
have that junior tournament here in st.
Louis and not only you do develop
friendships for a lifetime but it's also
amazing how successful these people then
in their careers and you know over the
last 30 years almost every one of these
people that participate are very
successful people to make up the names I
don't recall so we have max to loogie
there's a grandmaster patrick wolf that
guy and we had Stewart Rachel's so right
and then been fine gold has been rezoned
alabaster here right exactly so it was a
fun group and it's been great to know
those guys over the years what do you
think is taking the cinco cup home this
year these guys are all good so i'm
gonna be non-committal what's that we've
all had to bet so you got to give us one
name of course anybody could win that
that's a hedging your bets for real
there I mean for what I've seen veselin
to Powell office had some good positions
i'm not sure about his position right
now but he's looked pretty good so far
fabiano I i think is you know made st.
Louis is home and I think we're all
rooting for him sting a bit I'm
capacities okay fabiano thank you okay
that's all you guys can say Doug Eckert
thank you so much for all the work that
you do for chest here in st. Louis we
really appreciate it great thank you
very much